if you are in love with multiple
things that make you happy how do you
pick one
flipping a coin the questions are
confusing because people are actually
asking which one will make me more money
and i'm saying [ __ ] the money you just
want to be happy you like them all
you've won and you'll never know what
would happen you just never know so flip
a coin you've already won if everything
makes you happy just pick one people
like to dance around and play with [ __ ]
like no i don't know like they like the
mockery of the indecisiveness it's
almost like the self-deprecating kind of
like drama let's say you picked the
right thing it was the laundry mat not
the wine business and it was right you
did 10 times more business but on this
day when you went to the laundry store
to [ __ ] open the store a bus killed
you and if you did the [ __ ] wine
thing you would have made 20 less money
but you would have lived to 92. life's
[ __ ] unpredictable [ __ ] pick one
and go
right well thank you
i'm on fire i'm feeling tight clip that
[ __ ] up